ah ah
et oui enfin regarder on est là on en
parle c'est le nouveau smartphone de
wentworth alors le nouveau smartphone
aux bonnes places elles bonnes places 10
pro il est là il est déjà ouvert mais
quelques temps la muse avec bien
évidemment mais je voulais quand même
passer par une petite partie à une bo xi
rapide sur cette vidéo alors ici je vais
pas vous donner la fiche technique je
voulais déjà présenté ce smartphone
parce que je les ai vus au mwc à
barcelone où il a été exposé bien avant
le lancement officiel en europe parce
que déjà été présenté en chine en amont
c'est la raison pour laquelle je l' ai
vu et je vous ai déjà présenté donc si
vous voulez tout savoir sur la fiche
technique je vous mets un lien quelque
part pour aller voir la vidéo du wan
pluzz dix pros sur la présentation la
première prise en main ce qu'on fait ici
on va faire un tour rapide d'un côté
unboxing ya toujours une jolie
expérience à faire c'est sûr les médias
quitte c'est pas le kit que vous aurez
vous ce quart intérieur c'est ce que
vous aurez vous mais on va regarder et
puis on va gagner dans une deuxième
partie de la vidéo bien évidemment le
taisent les mon retour complet sur ce
one + 10 pro intéressant one + qui
s'opposent fille au pauvre fille fico
post ification contre on peut dire ça
comme ça mais qui pour autant peut
toujours de très jolies promesses avec
sur une deuxième année un partenariat
avec castle blade au niveau de la photo
également de la vidéo donc on va tous
regardé ça c'est chouette parce que ce
smartphone il a un design très
particulière moi j'aime bien le design
ces différences et différenciant par
rapport à ce qu'on est en marche et il y
en a qui aiment pas trop ces espèces de
très très gros modules pas ce que vous
en pensez vous est ce que ça vous plaise
module photo pas dites le moi dès
maintenant comment tu as très curieux de
savoir ça est ce que vous aimez il ya
question qui était posée il ya pas
longtemps nous avons intégré quand il
voit vraiment moi j'aime pas du tout ça
c'est vraiment un mot moi je dis j'aime
bien que c'est différent c'est assez
marrant et pour le coup ça me dérange
pas voilà alors j'attends votre avis
marqué le mois dans les commentaires
allez on y va on commence tout de suite
parce qu'il faut aller vite mais juste
avant le générique vim
alors on y gagne en nous alors ça vous
l'aurez pas malheureusement ce sont les
médias quitte de one love qui vont
repartir d'ailleurs très bientôt à
l'intérieur vous c'est ce que vous aurez
vous c'est cette petite boîte là et
j'aime bien les médias qui de one love
pas ce qu'ils racontent toujours une
jolie histoire a dit vous voyez la photo
alors ce qui est intéressant ce qu'on
voit c'est le panorama c'est tout c'est
un format particulier ces formats de la
seule blague c'est comparable expand
très allongée en format de photos qui
est vraiment très différent ce qui est
super intéressant parce que je trouve
très immersif au niveau de la
photographie est super chouette alors
regardez lorsque j'ouvre shot online
place à ce bled donc là au pelage peut
venir 30 sage peut venir tirer c'est
joli c'est vraiment joli objet alors
après celui qui a posé sur le bureau en
fait je pense à regarder comme ça là
ouais ok ils ont mis des petites coques
de protection là haut que bon voilà ces
médias qui donc je passe très rapidement
ça c'est par contre ce que vous allez
avoir c'est là la boîte du smartphone en
elle-même one + 10 pro toujours du rouge
toujours les couleurs de douane pluzz
co-développé avec castle blade and soul
blade je vous passe un peu le truc ce
sont des appareils photo de légende tout
simplement cdu extrêmement très haut de
gamme mais juste juste magnifique alors
on avait déjà vu j'ai trouvé que c'était
très intéressant c'était fait d'un lien
avec la première version et après il ya
des trucs intéressants ont servi à ce
rapprochement au pot en place et deux
par le rapprochement on a vu que one
place à apporter à oppose le partenariat
avec un seul bug on a notamment parlé au
niveau du au pot find x5 pro super
intéressant et on retrouve ici sur la
deuxième année en tout cas si olympus
donc ici qu'est ce que je ne trouve pas
grand chose a toujours une petite coque
de protection je pense que vous l'aurez
vous avec il ya toujours des petites
infos là dedans ce qu'elle à l'aide de
pete maison il ya là l'aide de pics maïs
et de palau welcome à seul blade voilà
l'athlète est la bce était plus grande
halle à l'aide de pythagore le petit
message ou à l'api tu nous as écrit pitt
local fondateur de la boîte avec deux
corées en votre tiroir de cartes sim ici
le petit
de démarrage laurent la carte de
garantie que ça épuise d'information
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a là dedans
hop un blog de charges bien évidemment
regarder le petit baume de charbon ça ça
change pas grand chose on sait donc des
charges qu'on a chez one love qui sont
assez et lancer la 80 watts et de la
superbe look alors super vous si vous
connaissez bien les termes superbook
c'est un terme de au pot est
effectivement une fois de plus c'est
loupé fifi l'opposé fication l'opo fini
fication de one place donc ont été lésés
les blocs de charge ici c'est du super
bowl je me rappelle plus tard que
j'utilise avant mais dont la technologie
d'auto qui est une technologie qui est
une recharge très rapide un super
intéressante avec un câble en usb usb
ces news léa ici et puis voilà c'est
tout c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
montrer pour cette grande première
partie ici qu'est ce que je vais trouver
intéressant alors je veux pas rentrer
dans les specs une fois de plus c'est ce
grand écran immersif et lumineux donc ça
ça me convient bien je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant légèrement incurvé
sur le côté moi j'aime bien ces écrans
légèrement incurvé je sais pas si c'est
votre cas mais ça c'est cool c'est un
truc qui me plaît bien que je trouve
vraiment intéressant il ya un truc que
je trouve intéressant se trouve un petit
peu en dessous c'est la partie audio je
vais vous mettre une vidéo pour vous
puissiez vous en rendre compte
lorsque je pousse le son à fond c'est
assez fort par rapport à d'autres
smartphones que j'ai testé notamment le
chiot médiocre mais pas aussi puissant
de construit puissant par contre il ya
un vrai déséquilibre entre le haut
parleur principal que vous avez là une
2e son côté au cerveau par leurs deux
renforts il va apporter effectivement un
peu de renfort ce côté pour la
spécialisation par contre c'est à ces
médiums et vous allez voir ça s'accroche
à ses portes à les
voiliers
je met un peu pour récupérer les apartés
prémédia mans voilà donc on a un certain
déséquilibre donc c'est pour cette
expérience là ce que je vous recommande
quand même si vous n'utilisez un casque
connecté en bluetooth ça serait quand
même plutôt pas mal ici c'est le premier
truc autre truc qui est intéressant on
va le retrouver effectivement pour le
gamer pour limoux aussi à tous qui est
très rapide voici un petit jeu on a
quand même vachement performance ici
gras sauce la dragonne 8,2 g première
génération alors y'a un truc intéressant
tu sais qu'ici je vais avoir 12 igad ah
ok je vais me dire c'est bien c'est de
la lpddr2 giga de ram c'est ratisser les
actifs savons combien ok mais y'a un
truc qui est intéressant et qu'on
retrouve ici et qu'on retrouve également
chez au pot c'est que vous avez de la
ram virtuel allez vas-y passe on passe
c'est fini on récupère les lauriers
bravo merci beaucoup donc c'est un
smartphone qui est très rapide et si
vous en voulez plus c'est un truc qui
est pas mal vous venez dans vos réglages
et dans vos réglages vous allez dans à
propos de l'appareil vous voulez la
regarder et là ils vous marquent bien
vous avez 12 giga de ram + 3 giga
pourquoi pas ce que pouvaient venir
augmenter la rame en pilonnant le rhum
c'est à dire en puisant dans le stockage
donc ça vous permet d'augmenter votre
ram donc la leaf plus vite et de gagner
en fluidité alors ça va dépendre une
fois de plus de ce que vous allez vous
vivre en terre sainte et ou qu'un petit
peu logiciel c'est un petit hack je
trouve ça assez marrant à l'image de
rajouter +7 ce qui fait que la en fait
vous arrivez à 19 giga de ram donc
l'idée est assez énorme alors temps de
pause qui n'a pas pris la laure ce que
stockage suffisant donc anormalement
j'ai rien n'y a pas grand chose dans le
truc donc on peut y aller et il
n'affiche pas pourquoi elle ça va des
fois c'est possible qu'un petit blog
mais bon elle est bien pousser à fond
pas pourquoi ça me passionne tu me lemay
ouais il veut pas si j'ai nommé comme
samantha sur l'âme avec 5 ils ne le
feront pas bon j'en sais rien
normalement il faut rajouter cette donc
je trouve que là c'est marrant quand ça
marche ce qui n'est pas qu'à tout de
suite vous permet d'augmenter un peu
l'histoire ça c'est plutôt bien alors
y'a un truc que j'aime bien ici mais ça
j'ai déjà dit c'est oxygène os oxygène
mauvaise j'aime bien sûr que
l'expérience est vachement intéressante
on peut venir la personnaliser il ya pas
mal de choses il ya les modes qui vous
permet de couper du monde vous allez
avoir rappelé à cette petite partie en
haut à droite avec votre petit centre
c'est pas sûr de notification vous avoir
accès rapidement à plein de petites
applications saas est assez marrant une
fois de plus signée one pleuvent trouve
c'est pas mal les notifications seront
justement ici là sur le côté plutôt bien
fichu nos expériences logiciel j'aime
bien vous avez aussi un espace de jeux
auxquels pourraient venir à voir vos
jeux optimiser enregistré l'écran enfin
bref couper les appels lorsque vous
jouez vous voulez pas être embêté donc
je trouve ça c'est marrant non sac de ce
point de vue là en terme de performances
on a un smartphone qui est complet qui
va bien maintenant le truc que je crois
un peu moins c'est cet écran il est très
beau mais il est très réfléchissants c
est un vrai petit miroir moi je me vois
beaucoup de dents regardez alors l'ailé
est un donc je parle assez normal qu'on
puisse savoir le nom mais je trouve
quand même assez réfléchissant bon après
c'est pas extrêmement grave autres qu'on
leur trouve qu'on connaît sur une
pelouse bien c'est effectivement ce
petit bouton là quelques jours se
pratique pour venir switcher vous coupez
leçon aux plats vous mettez en vibreur
et vous mettez en scène éric donc ça
c'est vraiment la seule marque
aujourd'hui qui fait ça donc si vous
avez besoin d'un smartphone ou voulaient
rapidement devenir switcher voyez entre
je coupe tout je veux uniquement les
vibrations ou alors je veux que ça sonne
et ben ça c'est vachement cool il ya que
one pluzz qui le fait donc je trouve ça
vachement bien capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui fonctionne bien aussi là
dessus j'ai absolument rien à rajouter
la batterie est un mauvaise on va tenir
une journée une journée et demie ça va
dépendre si vous jouez énormément ou pas
mais on tient une journée n'y a pas de
souci pour tous il fait plus comme vous
avez ce blog en charge très rapide de 80
watts et bien vous leurs charges
extrêmement rapidement non qu'on se pose
plus trop la question si vous voulez en
fait de la recharge et toutes ces
nouvelles générations de smartphones que
ce soit comme le xiaomi avec son chien
mais 12 avec une enchère 67 voix que ce
soit les chiffres nous disent pro avec
une recharge 120 watts on voit qu on
augmente les ouates lassé des batteries
by cellulaire en fait ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'à l'intérieur d'un
smartphone vous avez deux petites
batteries et elles vont venir se
recharger indépendamment l'une de
l'autre permet d'aller plus vite au
niveau de la charge alors lorsque vous
avez une charge 80 watts vous n'êtes pas
80 watts tout le temps et savent où l'on
cherche pas 80 watts à fond vous avez un
pic de charge de quelques secondes et 80
watts ensuite ça descend ça diminue sa
dix minutes j'ai fait une vidéo sur les
batteries pour vous expliquer ça donc ça
vous intéresse si vous êtes curieux vous
les soirs plâtre sur les batteries je
vous mets le lien quelque part par là
aussi non la vidéo est sur la chaîne ou
ailleurs c'est vachement cool on apprend
plein de choses après il ya un truc à
moi c'est toute la partie photo vidéo
alors la partie photo vidéo intéressante
je vais pas vous refaire les specs je
voulais déjà présenté mais il ya un truc
qui est vachement intéressant c'est que
vous avez une grosse grosse grosse
modularité et notamment grâce à ce
partenariat avec un seul bay alors je
vous montre la partie photo elle plutôt
cool vous avez un premier grand tante
qui est stabilisée qui est plutôt pas
mal la partie software je trouve aussi
intéressante de ce côté là j'ai voulu
détailler vous avez bien évidemment cet
ultra grand temps qui n'est pas
stabilisée qui lui va bouger on a douze
fois 2003 optique qui va être stabilisée
et donc ça c'est cool pour un mec comme
moi croyez-moi ça c'est plutôt important
gardez vous pouvez switcher entre votre
grand angle votre télé objectif en
anglais votre ultra grand temps mais
vous avez à notre mode qui existe et je
vous ai déjà présenté 6e au pot c'est
chez au pont je vais présenter ou pas
c'était chez au pot chez plus qu'il est
chiot pour peut-être pas c'est le 150
degrés alors le 150 degrés c'est en fait
un ultra grand temps qui n'est pas
corrigée qui a une des formations
donnent donc si vous voulez vraiment un
très grand truc est déformé il est
aujourd'hui les constructeurs vous
permettre de le faire pour autant est-ce
que c'est bien non c'est pas beau mais
si vous voulez profiter du maximum
première joute est ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez la voir comme ça mais ma
promo de fiches alors est-ce qu'il ya
besoin d'un mot si schalke ça sert à
quelque chose non mais si vous voulez du
fichage vous pouvez la voir mes autres
modes que je trouve vraiment intéressant
c'est surtout ce mode qui est vraiment
dédié à seul blake qui est vraiment
particulier c'est le x palais l'expulsa
tellement chouette vous permet de
prendre une photo vraiment faim on a
très très très allongé alors attention
pour venir corriger votre expo ici ansu
explose on vient augmenter légèrement
donc attention à pas faire n'importe
quoi mais voyez je cause ce format est
super bien d'être de très très beaux
résultats enfin pour venir faire
également de la vidéo alors ça je vous
l'avais montré de la vidéo jusqu'à 8
capes ce qui est assez bluffant ça c'est
grâce au sein dragon 8 de première
génération on peut venir le faire mais
si vous voulez stabiliser la par contre
on vous descend en 1080p et hop la poya
switcher enquête cas mais en tout cas
vous n'êtes pas stabilisée pour avoir
lustre à stabilité ont bien passé en
1080p mais bon déjà comme vous allez ici
une optique principal qui est stabilisé
vous pouvez y aller il y aura absolument
aucun problème il ya plein de petits
mode qui sont super sympas comment bien
faire effectivement de la photo vous
avez le mode pro avec castle blade ou là
si vous voulez venir vous amuser si vous
êtes amoureux de la photo il ya plein de
petites choses à venir à gratter alors
attention à ceux qui n'y connaissent
rien abstenez vous parce que vous allez
vraiment vous emmerdez que votre
triangle d'exposition mais y'a de quoi
faire un niveau de la balance des blancs
de parfaire plein plein plein de trucs
vous avez un petit histogramme pour vous
y repérer vous allez pouvoir venir
choisir votre lentilles directement ici
bref je trouve ça très bien fait il ya
d'autres modes aussi que je voulais vous
montrer qu'ils sont très sympas d'un
point de vue purement software ont
panoramique on s'en fiche ce film si on
veut mais bon ralenti time lapse la
pause donc sur ces moments si vous
voulez venir shooter avec en plus des
petits filtres pour venir ajouté à
l'histoire on peut le faire je me suis
amusé avec mon c'est marrant mais ça
casse pas quatre pattes à un canard vous
avez le duel view pour venir filmer
alors vous allez avoir d'un côté et bien
ce qu'il y ait dans la caméra derrière
et de l'autre côté vous devant donc ça
c'est pareil mais tous les constructeurs
le font aujourd'hui et je trouve ça
assez rigolo ouvriers ou métier comme ça
a picture in picture un rectangle on
peut fractionner c'est assez marrant et
puis sinon je crois que je vous à peu
près tout montrer les clean et son
décalage s'agit je montrerai veille des
photos en quelques instants le fameux
mode portrait ici mais je trouve que
c'est très complet est vraiment cool one
place a bien bossé avec ce partenariat
avec un soleil j'imagine que ça seul
blake qui leur a filé toutes les
recommandations mais ils ont dû venir
derrière valider certaines choses donc
ce smartphone il est vachement mais vous
allez voir le reste allait plutôt dans
quelques instants parce que croyez moi
c'est quand même le front attendu que je
n'ai pas montré dans la partie photo
lorsque vous êtes dans le mode pro à
seule l'aide et bien regardez vous venez
là et pouvait venir shooter jusqu'au
alors il ya des robes bien évidemment il
ya des rues plus l'euro plus c'est quoi
c'est un ro 12 bits autant vous dire
qu'ici il ya un paquet d'informations si
vous utilisez votre smartphone et après
récupérer les fichiers faire de la
retouche avec essayer le mode raw puce
ok il est temps de regarder le résultat
des photos des vidéos puis de débriefer
un peu globalement sur ce smartphone
pour savoir ce qu'il raconte alors je
vous montre quelques photos je suis venu
souhaiter ça ça me paraît pas mal on va
avoir il ya plein modes plein de modes
différents pour bien faire des photos
avec ce one + 10 programmes d' assez
rapidement là on est sur une photo sont
toutes assez standard ou quesada pas
trop mal je passe sur l'ultra grand il
est vachement plus ternes la suite très
grand temps pour regarder la différence
que vous avez là haut niveau la
luminosité de la photo c'est assez
dingue on va notamment au niveau du
blanc voyez gardez pas c'est vachement
plus terne on continue la chanson ultra
grand-angle normal là je suis passé sur
l' ultra grand-angle 150° vous le voyez
hein ça cette déformation sur les côtés
qui font un peu l'anti alors il ya un
petit bout de doigts qui est venu se
traînait par là et ensuite on peut
passer en mode fisheye en fait celle
ultra grand-angle si vous voulez que
vous allez avoir sans correction
ultra-grand-angle normales avec la
correction des groupes sur le côté et
ensuite on passe sur 150 degrés là il ya
plus de correction du tout ok et ensuite
on peut venir zoom et jusqu'en x 30
attaquons à foix zoom optique x 3,3 fois
5 il n'y a pas de grande différence
entre le faux 33 une fois 5 on va
regarder ça le x 10 et le x 20 x 30
regardez je suis ou néo max bref c'est
pas fait pour me résumer dans l'eau
parce que le résultat est pas ou qu'est
ce que je vous ai sorti si pareil c'est
une jumelle hazoumé la haye est bon il
ya un moment c'est du zoom numérique
donc au delà du x 3 3 x 5 on peut venir
faire on va pas aller au delà le x 10 et
le foie gras on va vraiment pas le faire
c'est pas terrible là vous avez un mode
avec une expo un petit peu longue pour
venir avoir des effets au niveau de
l'eau effet mouvement bon c'est assez
marrant peut-être que ça serait un peu
bluffant sur une grande cascade la voyez
ça ne donne pas un résultat de fous là
on a un mode aussi qui est un peu
particulier alors ce mode là il
s'appelle l'inclinaison décalage donc
bon ok ok on continue capteur principal
l'ultra grand angle bon et je trouve que
c'est pas hyper saturé c'est un peuple
un fait on va continuer à vous allez
voir et là je trouve que c'est pareil il
ya un effet un peu voilent sur la photo
il ya un truc qui me dérange alors je me
dis que c'est peut-être une question
logiciel pourtant je suis bien sûr
dernière version du logiciel est ce
qu'il va y avoir une mise à jour pour
qu'on récupère plus de couleurs plus de
saturation c'est pas l'un regarder la
voyez c'est par elles sont qu'un petit
filtre blanchâtre qui s'est posé devant
niveau du traitement je trouve pas sur
hbo alors là je vous ai mis le côté avec
le x pagne que j'aime bien j'aime bien
ce format mais on a la même chose que ça
manque de saturation sais c'est pas
c'est pas ouf quelques petites photos la
nuit alors les photos la nuit ça me fait
une expo à plus longue de quelques
secondes histoire de venir et bien faire
des choses un peu mieux et vous allez
voir qu'il ya vachement de flou alors le
relais sur le capteur principal luttera
grand-angle il à proscrire complet il
est pas beau du tout et voyez là il ya
un truc là c'est assez net on lit sans
le panneau lahore emplacements délimités
et dès que je la only plus grand chose
donc je sais pas je ne sais pas sur quoi
tout n'est pas où là c'est pareil voyez
c'est ça bouge vachement pour voir qu'on
a une cabine stable là dessus je sais
que c'est l'expo longue qui fait que en
fait c'est pas la bonne idée ça ça
marche pas des masses lui trente ans je
voulais faire de vous le montrer mais
c'est pas dingue et là bon encore celle
là c'est pas la pire ça c'est pas trop
mal je m'étais bien qu'elle ait les
mains et là regardez c'est pareil je le
tiens à la main c'est complètement
comme si elle pas de stabilisation en
fait envoyé on voit que ça bouge et si
au niveau des plantes c'est pas demain
il pareil ici on voit que ça a bougé au
niveau du bon c'est très très surprenant
il ya que celle là qui est un peu moins
pire mais c'est vrai que en photo nue
son passager et là c'est pareil au
niveau de la gestion au niveau des
lumières se trouve pas ça
particulièrement dingue après sinon la
recette marche pas trop mal mais il ya
un truc au niveau de la stap qui est qui
qui est pas là et voiles et voiliers
jamais ça me transcende pas gelé ses
doigts dessus bravo monsieur gros aux
photos que je veux shooter ici et c'est
pareil c'est à peu près la même chose je
vais venir dire ici c'est à dire que je
trouve que les photos elle manque un peu
de pitié comme un petit voilages blancs
fait devant voyez ça manque de précision
ça monte de netteté ça manque de
saturation rien certaines marques est
sursaturé là pour le coup je trouve ça
trop flat alors il ya différents trucs
vous voyez là c'est l'ultra grand temps
le setra grand temps il est un peu
déformant sur le côté alors là je suis
venu me rapprocher un petit peu c'est le
foie trois et demi doit être le x 5
s'arrête le foie dit ça ça doit que le x
20 et voyait que le résultat il est pas
ouf j'ai fait xpan c'est un format que
j'adore et je trouve vraiment beau donc
ça c'est plutôt cool et là je voulais
fait directement de même endroit avec le
150° au point coulant voit vraiment que
c'est quand même très déformant et
l'effet fisheye c'est normal aux photos
ici je n'eus chuté également donc avec
le grand angle ok bon sinon on voit bien
la façade du bâtiment on voit bien le
ciel ok mais à rien tout qui marchent
pas l'ultra grand angle aussi c'est
pareil sauf qu'il ya un truc qui
fonctionne pas à quoi et je trouve quand
même un peu des formes hans ultra
grand-angle injection n'est pas dingue
bon là tu 150° forcément sa courbe et
c'est normal le fisheye c'est normal on
vient où mais faut trois et demi face à
un accès très terne al x 5 1 vous
regardez ici fois dix fois vingt sais
pas où est le xpan j'aime bien le format
mais au-delà de ça ça change pas grand
chose et c'est un peu là puisque je vais
vous montrer un peu à droite à gauche
voyez c'est je trouve que ça manque de
saturation ça manque de piqué il ya un
truc voilà alors tu es que d'un point de
vue logiciel ça peut être corrigé par la
suite mais foyer sinon regardez là c'est
pareil regardez j'ai l'impression que
c'est un voile blanc devant donc je
pense que c'est un truc software en fait
inclure une mise à jour qui viendra
corriger ça mais en l'état ce chiffre
est derrière nous et je trouve que c'est
pas assez pas ou quoi voilà c'est pas
vous fait pour voir que j'ai un
smartphone ou que j ai marqué un seul
blake derrière abou voilà bon vous voyez
ça c'est le monde des choses sympa sinon
regarder et même place des vosges où
j'aime bien venir a shooté à paris je
trouve que le verrier ressort pas des
masses voilà il ya un truc qui marche
pas c'est pas très beau en fait et c'est
un taux déceptif la caméra de selphy
pareil pas ouf ça vient pas trop lisse
et bastos manque vachement de piqué dans
l'image niveau des hautes lumières là
c'était pas dingue dingue os x ça manque
vraiment de précision et c'est vraiment
ce qui va bien me dire roger ici donc
bon je reste vraiment sur un truc un peu
en demi teinte je me dis que c'est
peut-être une mise à jour logicielle qui
va venir corriger ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok ça peut paraître surprenant mais je
devine qu en 1080p que les caméras de
cette fille ça c'est la caméra de celle
ci et là je le vois ça bouge énormément
alors j'ai un mode convenir stabiliser
ça bouge à part toujours en 1088 même
distance au niveau du bradage une perf à
celle ci en fait ça se produise mieux ça
c'est d'un point de vue purement
électronique mais je suis uniquement
1080p de la vidéo et en 4k donc voyez
c'est pas assez pas magique mais bon
j'ai de la 4k l'arrière mais uniquement
l'arrière d'ailleurs là tout de suite
c'est en train de filmer chez en 8 kg
plus que la 4 car elle est restée tient
à bout de bras j'ai l'impression qu'une
stable alors ya de l'eau y est quand
même un an qu'une stable au-dessus
optique
mais sapin l'air ouf je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez d'ailleurs doublement
commentaires bien je vous montre la cap
car 1 4 kg à l'arrière là c'est tout de
suite beaucoup mieux gardés en marchant
c'est beaucoup mieux stabilisé j'ai
l'impression que le smartphone le gère
beaucoup mieux après si je souhaite je
peux venir zoomer dézoomer
vous met tout doucement comme si je
voulais faire du cinéma à la zouze
cinématiques sco x 10g pas bien plus
loin et on suit je peux venir des hommes
est comme ça et je vais ensuite son
ultra grand temps ci je souhaite fils
mais qu'on y travaille en temps comme ça
si je me filmer mois ultra-grand-angle
là je peux le faire nous rapprocher
aussi un petit peu comme ça doit me
rapprocher énormément comme ça pour
venir filmer l ultra grand-angle en cas
de carton ni hd sur la caméra arrière
mais le mieux quand même s'il utiliser
la caméra principale regardez là comme
ça hop laisser les différentes expos pas
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire ça
vous plaît ça vous plaît pas aux boks à
vous battre pas c'est un smartphone qui
est vachement intéressant parce qu'en
termes de performance il est là il
marche bien je peux lui attribuer de la
ram virtuel qui va dire booster un peu
plus j'ai de la recharge rapide je
trouve pas mal j'aime bien le format
donc l'expérience audio global sonore
multimédia me convient bien la
performance derrière et là mais je
trouve qu'il est vraiment sain au niveau
de la photo sur le modèle que j'ai là en
tout cas peut-être qu'une mise à jour
logicielle viendra corriger mais bon en
tout cas ce que j'ai l'habitude dans les
mains c'est pas un smartphone que je
vais venir dire ok il est super faut y
aller et pour autant on est quand même
un certain prix et voilà je reste un peu
sur ma faim soit reconnaître je peux
guère vous en dire plus aujourd'hui je
trouve que l'intégration photo à seul
blade était vachement réussi sur le open
bic cinq pros extrêmement bien réussi
donc c'est maxi on se dit que sur vos
smartphones avec une griffe à seul ben
aujourd'hui je vous dirai plus aller
chez au pot que chez one place alors
effectivement dacquois on à 250 euros
300 presque 300 euros d'écart c'est une
certitude mais voilà je suis pas
convaincu par ce que je vois ici sur ce
one places dispos et c'est un peu
dommage qu est-ce que vous emportez de
ce que je vous ai montré en photo mais
ce qu'on pensait de ce smartphone est ce
qu'il vous ait pas du tout où est ce que
comme moi vous reste un voilà je sais
pas bon on en reparle je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt le
chaos
[Musique]